how's Gomer as many welcome back to
chapter three of the evil within we just
had a little nice little bath
that was very relaxing and we just feel
nice rejuvenated chic and ready to hit
the dance floor maybe not so much we
escaped a bunch of zambese I don't even
know how the [ __ ] we did that we just
unlocked our Spanish powers just for a
second or some [ __ ] but this place looks
so much better maybe 9 claws of the
Horde chapter 3 that sounds great
hi crow how crow [ __ ] a syringe thank
you appreciate it
stupid box alright so yeah they put
curtains up here for me that's so nice
stupid barrel piece of [ __ ] any game
where you can just beat up barrels this
is Otto 10 out of 10 for me Oh oh god
they're cuddling I don't trust this for
one [ __ ] second I don't have any I
don't have any that guy is totally
groping that ass is that intentional
what are you doing wedding the police
shows up at the dead parents house it'd
be like Gary died but he died happy
groping is oh here we go alright groping
bad eh yes
oh nice I like how they melt and [ __ ]
smells like one direction I love it yeah
and I would not go through doors that
open by themselves in real life
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] don't quote me what do we
got here
an abandoned [ __ ] creepy house I
think I remember this place oh man we've
been here you know in the wind played
the demo it seems kind of familiar
I'm sure we'll get there eventually yes
this oh nice and axe can we take that
I'll take that thank you seeing this
game you're not a [ __ ] is running from
[ __ ] you can chop and [ __ ] that's
right
I'll chop all the meats that I need to
chop ma pizzas camming but come this way
mind all the bytes do we have a syringe
luckily let's use it sorry breaths try
not to [ __ ] up
can't can't oh nice yeah so this is the
place kind of when we were in the demo
those things chased me all the way into
the village me too
they're all over the place
and we just kill them how the [ __ ] did
Leslie manage to go through there don't
like the saint or the one with the gun
don't look at me like that you're the
one with the gun
what does this do I love cranking it's
my favorite hobby
what are we opening here exactly like
what what do we do he looks so Sugoi
alright so my job is to distract them or
no his job is to distract him
that old guys gonna get himself killed
yeah why did he sacrifice his torch
dumbest thing ever
that's right stupid door let's see if we
can find loot was this a bed oh no I
don't want hi I'm not a [ __ ] maybe I
should actually probably don't [ __ ] me
oh nice should know his head is blown up
he's not coming
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what is he doing don't
point I'm a stupid [ __ ]
love the noises they made it turns me on
very nice how did they find me oh [ __ ]
well thanks for telling me now
he's [ __ ] cute no okay
okay I remember these whoa I don't like
cuffs
I don't like theirs at all this is
really the kind of game where you need
to loot which I like yo Inc brain goats
white brain whatever I need those and I
need dos I need no I need the [ __ ] ax
give me the ax I'm not a [ __ ] I don't
have anymore syringes don't worry
brother
luckily you're here with a pro
ah nice where did she go some more notes
about ourself perhaps let's see first
day as a detective my new partner
Mira Hansen is a real firecracker
tenacious and non non cent and
no-nonsense my kind of woman
but I got to watch it around her she
almost caught me checking out her ass
today
nice sexual her a Asst for that alias
don't do it okay let's go yes we need to
save huh
I wonder if this is gonna play up to
something this whole thing where we go
between worlds and stuff I think so
Bruce I think so he also looks kind of
like how I imagined Daniel from amnesia
would look like
you remember thank you see if we can
upgrade something open place well I
guess not
there's a news article serial killings
continue please baffled by Casas death
how can they be seer trace of killer
interesting alright let's go through the
whole don't quote me on that don't quote
me on anything I ever said don't quote
me on this sentence in specific in
particular what English go through oh
nice very nice oh god it's alive oh my
god that's [ __ ] up oh god this place
is awful Lee nice I like what they done
with the place
okay alright there must what the [ __ ]
just happened
there's something to spell well I have a
spring GU please what the [ __ ] would
stupid don't think I need that I need
this heroine wonderful it makes me feel
all nice and fuzzy inside don't say no
to drugs bros
someone ever offers you drugs just put
your cap to the battle [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong shut up
I'm on your side
what's wrong with him I'm running did it
stupid Oh a sickle I sure love sickles
no popsicles if you know what I mean I
think he knows I'm here I'm Phil just
making that noise
this is groaning is that you Peggy Peggy
what are you doing
Peggy all right we better sneak up on
Peggy yeah yeah yeah come on pay yes
buttes said dude hey Peggy you're so
cute you're so cow hey what's that noise
come that's a trap their piggy JP let's
hit the trap I wish I could set the trap
so that I can use them against damn bees
that'd be cool
is that [ __ ] noise coming from some
kinky [ __ ] is going on
I say Bruce some kinky [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I think it's upstairs and I want a
mesquite
[Music]
I got a trap going on here I don't
understand
is it weird I don't I don't think we're
gonna like what we're gonna see up here
bris uh what the fudge cake it's going
on here Bryce beer Trappe now now no one
will be hurt I am just the savior of the
animals I think we should go up it's a
trap though I don't think I don't see
you oh god what's going on
I can lit that on fire that's kind of
cool hey they're not hard but they make
me nervous okay what are we gay okay
similar Steph sweet Bruce nice little
basket dad it's awesome nicer in these
games aren't too hard Wolf Wolf revolver
guns stuff they're not too hard as long
as he loot
I think stupid door where the [ __ ] am I
going let's just keep going up
like I said I don't think we like what
we see up here I think you both should
probably close your eyes don't worry
I'll tell you when it's safe Bros what
this is totally fine this is a bunch of
loot I'm full on the loot even brain goo
I can always have more room though okay
well I think there's a glitch if I let
go look I don't think damage what the
[ __ ] is up with stupid Oh Jeff my own
shadow scared me I'm such a badass
that's what they call me in school it
was cuz my ass was flat and ugly
just like Miley and cannulate that's
cool why would I climb down if I don't
take damage for like that must be a
glitch on a chest what did it OH
are you
Wow what a [ __ ] troll this game is
hard man
that's not fair is it
I'd to replay everything oh my god
I hate them come back we're back here
three hours later [ __ ]
Oh God nice are those ducks how dare you
when video games go too far that syringe
yeah I'll take that thank you
every time I'm so close
amazing I'm not gonna open that [ __ ]
bitch-ass [ __ ] chest this time though
I know there's a lot of monsters here so
I'm gonna be careful mate burn alright
woken one that's fine oh [ __ ] not fine
oh come on no bad bad beads yes it would
looks like that oh come on no I'm just
gonna go it's been great I think we
really had something there man but what
a man just gotta go a man's gotta go if
you know what I'm sewing I'm not sewing
anything actually don't check my Etsy
it's private don't okay we made it out
alive somehow some oh he's still he's
still being a little [ __ ] alright brain
goo who did that who did that okay I
don't like this brush I don't know if
he's still after me or anything he's
still give up I'm gonna pull this lever
now oh no I should have tied it better
okay I got it I got it I got it
I'll just run here like I'm the boss I
am and now I wait I wait I now pull it I
am now pulling it I killed one of them
think no he's still being a little [ __ ]
god damnit [ __ ] I should have burned
that one
don't waste your match if you don't know
how to snare sack guys I'm here just
come she figured it out no no no not so
fast now come on you're too fast
she runs too fast she Oh God
she runs too fast and then why don't you
come over here BAE and I'll make you a
sandwich
she will explode my sandwich are
explodable they're so delicious that she
becomes fish oh he doesn't see me I
think he will in a second now something
tells me he might find me smack my [ __ ]
up and Gary's playing with his bottle
come here hey great you guys could make
it
now make it rain on dem hoes make it
rain on them to make it Frank did you
guys could just come like a little
closer that'd be great thank you
hey what are you doing
yes oh my god I've been so pissed if you
deny give me all that [ __ ] a grenade
cool you [ __ ] threw an axe at me it's
[ __ ] crazy stupid [ __ ]
don't worry buzz I know exactly what I'm
doing
so let's pump some heroin in there thank
you thank you very much
all right now we can focus on what we
were doing
[ __ ] ourself that was amazing those
are poems more harpoons please game and
let me buy a shock too when you can
shoot those out of that it's like the
best part of that game said another cow
come on cow what are you doing no one
ships you with any one cow are we done
did we do it did we done diddly desolate
I feel like we deserve to have done it
it's Sara it's our thing there we go
let's investigate what what does this
chain do hmm great there's got to be
something that'll get through this maybe
a chain saw oh thank you I would love a
chain saw thank you very much the game
is like well you should go here listen
maybe ain't no mountain high ain't no
Valley low ain't no River wide enough
baby bear if you need me count on me no
matter where you are no matter how no
matter how far don't worry just come me
I'll be there in a hurry
you don't know
[Music]
what the [ __ ] I killed the pig oh my god
I should not have killed the pig note to
self
Oh God really I've been trying forever
to figure out what to do and all I had
aah Oh God
are you [ __ ] kidding me oh you
[ __ ] [ __ ] Tang Mei uh I destroyed a
pig that's all I had to do
Wow are there more pigs now I'm just
gonna go you'd be a good boy and you
stay there I hope he doesn't know how to
climb ladders and get what are you doing
all right now what we do is we take this
Renaud that I've been having saving for
a while okay all right and then we make
it go there that's a really good little
little gift that I that I am giving away
for free because I am such a gentleman
that I just want you all to feel happy
and confident about who you are and [ __ ]
me I'm so [ __ ] dead this is [ __ ]
ridiculous all right they're coming to
that's great
don't touch me if you don't like me I
mean if you'd like me don't if you if
you alright you're running like a I'm
gonna turn you on fire and see what
happens and then kick it on him
that's right I kicked it
oh yeah he's having trouble in Lille why
would you die yeah that was uh that was
not easy
yeah go back to your home master
nobody's aliasing I'm gonna grab all
that goo chainsaw check into this goo
disgustingness check a lot of [ __ ] check
senpai all right so now we're gonna go
for our epic loot if there's a
[ __ ] if there's a [ __ ]
bomb in here I swear to [ __ ] god
thank you I'll take that and that thing
thanks Dean yeah damn it alright lettuce
chain saw that that chain my god that's
the most clever thing I've said in my
laughs chainsaw the chain yes yes [ __ ]
yes
Oh just gonna feel good
yeah like that chain take that chain
don't need you anymore chainsaw cuz I'm
a man and my name is Sam come on
[ __ ] you damn that was a hard chapter it
took me over over one hour to finish it
let's do a save game there I'll probably
cut it down a little bit for you but I
hope you enjoy and appreciate what I
committed to with the chapter thing it's
really a big [ __ ] hassle but I do it
for you best so please go ahead and if
you enjoyed this far
leave a like I really appreciate it bros
and that's all we got our little mats
all I asking for you I'll see you in the
next one keep showing your support in
this series I really appreciate it bro
so stay us
[Music]